bonjour papilles bonjour je n'arrive pas
à envoyer deux clins d'oeil à quelqu'un
d' accord est un coup d'oeil et votre
projet vous n'avez l'été prochain
je n'ai jamais vraiment visiter deux
lieux remarquables ou tignes et intérêts
vous êtes linda terrain oui j'ai juste
déconnecté nous allons avoir le
privilège de publier le tout dernier
numéro de life magazine penta filet pour
ce dernier numéro nous venons de
recevoir le négatif 25 de sean o connell
qui fera la couverture et le 25
il y est pas je vois bien
la glace oui les bouches comme une femme
où étiez-vous je sonde les limites de
l'esprit humain je planterai bien mon
petit drapeau sur votre agathe salut
salut alors ses week-ends c'était super
waouh
comment tu appelle ça déjà quand il part
dans son monde il déconnecte tu fais ça
parfois qu'est ce que tu as
j'ai perdu une photo quand je vois je
vois la photo et la machine à rêves
quand je vous revois vous voyez la photo
vous devriez penser et laisser des
ministères
j'adore les mystères on pense que ça
colle pas
en fait on se rend compte que si eto'o
profite à l'ensemble
avant j'avais une idée précise de ce que
je voulais être
qu'est ce que je voulais faire
la vie ça manque du courage et des
sceaux dans la chronique